you guys love the other two among us
videos so we're back with the third one
we got laser beam jacksepticeye dream
and sap now whoa let's jump right into
the first game
darn it impostor again hey let's do it
jimmy okay
i don't believe them when they say that
all right who am i suspecting i want to
try and catch someone like before they
even kill someone i'm following chandler
i'm only moving when chandler moves mr
bass looking suss why isn't there any
money in this video mr beast why isn't
there any money oh carl you want to join
up on this all right we got the buddy
train quick and easy kill
gotta get out here get out of here get
out of here gotta get out of here no
why me it's always me get away from me
why is everyone over here following me
all right we're gonna run up there i
think i just got away with it i can't
believe i just got away with that no one
is no one's found my body there's
chandler and jimmy all right all right
okay
yes yes all right
i was just about to report it
yay i hovered over it no
this group doesn't have a lot of
experience i'm going to sit on cameras
and catch them in the act
lights are going to go off i'm going to
turn them on in 0.1 seconds
boom killer caught three down they
haven't even called a meeting yet we're
on fire we are unstoppable let's do this
carl killer cot okay
so i almost didn't want to report this
body because i'm the only one over in
specimen oh my god oh my god oh what
happened the killer is obviously
somebody who got some big brain listen
to chris toot his own horn i want to say
i was camping lights that entire time so
that's where i was the entire round nah
you went to the reactor mate suss of
laser because laser saw me camping
lights and lasers accusing me of not
keeping lights even though i was camping
lines we have to vote here i'm kind of
sus to believe maybe it's laser and
chris and chris got spooked because the
lights came back on early i agree i
think it's a hunter here's why i think
the last person i saw with jax podicy
was dream and car dream and spa dicey
fix and lights dream if you did go back
to where you said you did go back to
that means the last person spotted with
spadisi is carl hey guess what here's
the best part chris who did you just
vote for a dream yes okay jimmy let's
vote for dream and then he gets killed
and then we win okay you guys suck at
this game please get better me and jimmy
are the imposters
i voted for carl by the way just saying
wait carl i'm not an imposter
wow
wow just kidding
i called it ah carl stop killing me
first me and carl big brain the crap out
of you guys
dude two times in a row all right very
exciting i am a crewmate
okay we're gonna cut the lights off give
me them lights all right as far as i
know most of these guys aren't that good
so
i've been told to go super sweaty i
played a lot of among us with my squad
dream and sapnap but i've never played
with jacksepticeye and laser beam i
don't know whose names are what oh i'm
getting nervous we got a lot of big
brains here what are you doing laser cop
my chain was clear did his tasks mate
the task bar went up i'm not going to do
any tasks i'm just detective beam i'll
go away i don't know what people's
strategies are i'm doing weapons pew pew
pew here's me doing weapons here i am
i'm doing weapon oh no
reactor went off i'm gonna have chris
kill first i wonder what laser beam's
talking about right now surely not mr
basses imposter surely not he's either
talking about how i'm gonna kill him or
he's gonna kill me and i don't know
which oh no carl we should double kill
we should double kill let's go ahead and
reset this check this thing see if
there's anyone dead no everyone's alive
everybody's alive all of my friends are
still alive that's good chris just do a
kill all right well i've failed as a
detective because i've lost everyone i'm
going to go do some tasks
hearts beating oh oh nobody's dead yeah
whoever is imposter is really bad at it
so i say we just let him keep being
garbage let him keep doing it just do
tests no here's the thing i think it's
dream why yeah i hate that guy he he
walked a little funny you just walked
into me doing medicine that's enough for
me i'm voting i've stayed in my case up
to you guys i've done nothing i'm i'm on
med bay right now wait jimmy do you have
an actual reason i have an actual reason
i he walked funny walking funny is
enough get out of here buddy what the
are you kidding me wait you guys are
throwing bye dream
it's jimmy it's jimmy i'm telling you
it's jimmy it's jimmy it's jimmy jimmy's
throwing i'm surprised that worked i
have no idea what we just did all right
speedrun tactic i like it dream is out
that's the first person we needed he's
the biggest of the big brains i'm
totally cool with what just happened
what the hell
i was doing med bay i really hope he was
imposter i'm gonna just go ahead and
start getting as many kills as i can and
then carl will be not suss and then carl
can be the one that takes it to the dub
just staring at people creeping him out
a little bit laser's about to kill me
ladies are so about to kill me tending
to do tasks pretending to do tasks go
ahead and turn off electrical
is he gonna kill him please kill him in
the room kill him in the room please
lights are out right now he's probably
gonna kill me
oh what wow i can't even see you oh so
fun if no one's dying all right most of
these guys have probably never played
this map i'm gonna go check vitals and
see if someone's dead yeah there's
people in here about to die about today
about today about tonight well someone's
dead hey carol's here carol protects me
carol you're my shield card if i die
here it's your fault why is jack named
spadacey i'm gonna do an upload
oh
no it's this guy zap nap running out of
here i i don't know who that is but
they're in a police outfit uniform i
just keep only running into carl
are you kidding me in front of everybody
oh oh oh oh
all right i saw it i saw it it was chris
chris chris chris jimmy killed it oh my
god
him right in front of him no no no chris
just killed jack christopher
where's the body it was in right outside
of o2 i was coming down jimmy killed him
i ran over to report the body jimmy
reported because he saw me you didn't
see me coming down
all right hold up hold up let me just
say something chris i know what you're
doing because for content
yeah
i have knowledge laser what's your
knowledge what's your knowledge i saw
bass do a task i saw bass do a task and
the task bar went up there are times
where i like if i were to fake a task
i'd wait until the test bar moves up and
start walking it was a long task and he
was doing asteroids and it went up in a
long task amount stop now where were you
i'm in communications what if it's
carolina guys
i have been doing tests the entire time
it is chris
30 minutes
better than chris i swear to god no i
voted for chris cause i believe you all
right i'm voting chris i'm voting chris
chris killed someone in front of me i
swear to god the only reason i didn't
really have too too much sus on chris is
cause i literally walked past him like
30 seconds earlier did anybody else die
around bye bye chris admit you're an
imposter admit it you guys are dumb we
might lose right here oh that means it
was chris otherwise we would have lost
right all right well we might have
screwed up i'm still pretty sure it's
not mister basically okay so it wasn't
dream it's carol or sapnap yeah now it's
time to sabotage and i'm also gonna
follow jimmy around and close doors
because i hate him chris is dead and the
game's not over which means dream wasn't
actually an imposter and i feel kind of
bad i just start closing all the doors
make everybody's life annoying stop
closing doors chris please stop closing
doors chris please stop closing doors
chris please oh please don't kill me
carl please don't kill me carl please
don't kill me carl carl the only person
that's kind of proven right now is jimmy
i need to kill jimmy friends mean you
no
no
no
there's one imposter left i don't know
who it is but i'm going to figure this
out detective beast is on the case i
better go check if someone's dead don't
go into your car everyone's stick
together this are we the only people
alive bro hey no one's dead i need to
get a stack kill an electrical let's do
it let's do it oh the lights are going
out i'm spamming reforms family reports
i reckon it's call man he's the only one
who defended chris for some reason the
lights disappeared standing out there i
don't want to die carl why aren't you
turning on the lights carl why aren't
you turning on the lights that took carl
a suspicious amount of time i've done
almost no tasks the imposter has to kill
someone eventually dude i'm calling it
i'm going to call it i'm going to call
it i'm going to call it i'm going to
call it i'm going to be 400 iq i'm going
to be 400. all right so here's why i
think it's carl that's what i was going
to say wait why carl we're all like in
like this little area like waiting for
the lights to turn back on and the
lights took too long to turn on and then
i was the only person that went over to
turn it on yeah because you had to
because you'd be suspicious i went over
immediately you guys watched listen to
this when the lights were on and you
were all alone i didn't see a task for
go up at all which indicates you weren't
doing any tasks and someone also killed
chandler and we were all together here's
why i think it's carl the game would
have ended if we didn't get one of the
imposters and the only person defending
chris was carl i didn't defend chris i
said there's only one reason i don't
think it's chris guilty as charged i'm
voting we could be wrong carl laser
before you vote for a second voting on
four is stupid you know that oh we don't
we don't have to vote at all we don't
have to vote at all i already voted for
carl so yeah same nah voting on four is
very stupid i agree but we're stupid so
we're going for it okay actually that's
a bit that's a good point
that's a good point we just won we we
won that's raps that's gg chris what was
your plan hey that's right
right
get detective beam we are the smartest
people on the planet exactly we are a
big brain yes i had to make some big
plays curse a big play is not killing
somebody in front of somebody i hope you
gamers enjoy it if you're not already
hit that subscribe button i'll give one
of you a high five subscribe